[Musica]
sospettiamo da sempre i robot ci rubano
il lavoro
vediamo i robot intelligenti
abbiamo visto addirittura nel 1980
quindi i media dicevano il robot
prenderà il nostro lavoro seppure 1980
significa prima del pci prima che il pci
e mettesse è proprio il suo primo bit
negli anni sessanta in pieno boom
economico ancora si parlava del fatto
che questi lavori spariscono nel 35
quindi stiamo parlando di un'era fa e
continuiamo a vedere a leggere i
messaggi le macchine intelligenti allora
tutte queste notizie sono state errate
erano sbagliate queste previsioni perché
era facile prima misurare il lavoro che
sgorgava dalle nostre mani il lavoro
materiale oggi è molto più difficile
calcolare misurare il lavoro immateriale
il lavoro digitale che facciamo
e allora guardiamo un attimo questa
evoluzione
vedete che l'evoluzione tecnologica e
molto veloce da un telefonino semplice
di qualche anno fa oggi abbiamo una
capacità computazionale enorme abbiamo
applicazioni che possiamo fare tutto con
un telefonino
quindi la tecnologia cambia molto molto
rapidamente lo sappiamo però c'è un
altro livello il livello del lavoro che
effettivamente cambia un po più
lentamente perché adotta questa
tecnologia e poi cambia il lavoro
quello che cambia molto più lentamente e
la nostra capacità umana di adattarci a
questi cambiamenti
questa differenza effettivamente crea il
problema di questo gap di competenze che
abbiamo bisogno nel mercato
allora guardiamo un attimo quello che
diceva copernico ha detto guardate la
terra non è più al centro dell'universo
e il sole quindi abbiamo tolto un po di
centralità poi è iniziato darwin a dire
anche l'uomo però non è al centro del
regno animale
siamo in evoluzione bene
freud l'uomo non è trasparente a se
stesso cioè l'inconscio fino ad arrivare
a un punto importante during
l'intelligenza non è solo una
prerogativa dell'essere umano e questo
in comincia un po a destabilizzarci
perché arriverà una macchina che ci dirà
il lavoro non è soltanto qualcosa
dell'uomo e anche qualcosa che può fare
la macchina allora questa disciplina è
che noi chiamiamo intelligenza
artificiale i suoi elementi base sono
fatti da i dati quindi senza dati non
possono fare nessuna elaborazione nessun
calcolo la capacità computazionale
quindi l'hardware la potenza e poi gli
algoritmi
ecco queste tre elementi stanno
riducendo il loro costo di produzione di
elaborazione e quindi possiamo inserire
la predizione di queste macchine che ci
aiutano in vari business
a questo punto però dobbiamo riflettere
che cos'è per noi il lavoro ognuno di
noi ha una definizione però una delle
più belle secondo me è questa dove si
dice che si producono dei beni
guadagniamo un reddito e ci dà
soddisfazione
si dice anche che il lavoro nobilita
l'uomo allora sì è vero però noi siamo a
taranto ea taranto sappiamo che alcuni
lavori sono pericolosi
alcuni sono faticosi alcuni sono molto
noiosi molto ripetitivi questi tipi di
lavoro dobbiamo è meglio lasciarli alle
macchine per fare noi qualcos'altro
perché alla fine noi dobbiamo creare
questa piramide del valore è
posizionarci ovviamente c'è qualcuno che
ha il capitale lo investe e quindi può
fare questo tipo di lavoro ma chi non ha
il capitale può avere le idee le idee
nel senso della della creatività umana
quindi elaborazioni di immagini di libri
e così via
chi non ha il capitale chi non ha le
idee gli rimane il tempo e qui diventa
un po critica perché se una persona
soltanto il tempo da dare è una persona
che fa un lavoro ma potrebbe essere
sostituito facilmente perché non hanno
competenza specifica rientra nella massa
e qui parliamo di ascensore sociale
perché chi durante l'attività lavorativa
oggi non impara qualcosa non parla con
nessuno fa un'attività ma ripetitiva in
attività e al grandissimo rischio perché
può essere digitalizzata fatta fare o da
un'altra persona a salaria ancora più
bassi
oppure addirittura da una macchina
quindi chi ha la relazione diretta con
il cliente è sempre avvantaggiato
cliente o partner ovviamente da
un'analisi che abbiamo fatto abbiamo
visto che ci sono una serie di
competenze che richiediamo sul mercato
mi spiego
accanto alle competenze tecniche con le
specifiche quelli di bit e byte degli
specialisti
noi abbiamo visto una richiesta di skill
comportamentale cioè la capacità di
essere flessibili di lavorare con gli
altri di lavorare in team di gestire le
priorità questi queste richieste che
arrivano dal mercato
aprono opportunità enormi per ragazzi ma
anche e soprattutto per ragazze
abbiamo bisogno di donne che hanno
questo tipo di sensibilità da immettere
nel mercato così possiamo aiutarle a
recuperare questo gap che loro hanno
evidentemente e quindi siamo in una
condizione diciamo dove lavoriamo adesso
nola noi lavoriamo in europa siamo in
europa abbiamo l'evidenza di un mercato
americano guidato molto dal mercato il
mondo orientale e in qualche modo così
guidato dallo stato noi in europa
abbiamo anche una protezione perché
guardiamo al cittadino
nello specifico noi siamo a taranto a
taranto abbiamo avviato un progetto a
mio modo di vedere molto interessante
che si chiama peter dove in realtà
vogliamo fare una semplice realizzazione
di un'idea concreta l'idea è collegare
alcuni istituti alle ultime classi degli
istituti superiori taranto con il
politecnico di bari con il mondo del
lavoro
abbiamo avviato questo processo in
questi giorni quindi ufficialmente lo
possiamo affermare che sta portando una
serie di competenze di mentorship che
diamo con un progetto pubblico privato
dove facciamo in modo che queste persone
uomini e donne siano più collegate tra
loro anche verso il mercato del lavoro
per cui si chiama e new collar non c'è
più quella distinzione netta che c'era
tra colletti bianchi quindi gli
impiegati o colletti blu gli operai new
collera sono coloro che hanno questo
tipo di competenze digitali per il mondo
che richiede queste competenze e allora
quali sono i lavori che stanno
diminuendo
diminuiscono sia come quantità sia come
stipendi come vi dicevo i lavori
meccanici lavori ripetitivi dove si
richiede la precisione e velocità e non
solo più lavori umani questi lavori
pian piano si riducono per fortuna però
abbiamo anche una serie di lavori che
restano più o meno stabili lavori di
manageriale di venditori e così via sono
diciamo così
attività che restano in piedi quello che
è molto più importante sono i lavori che
stanno crescendo in quantità numerica
importante perché noi non abbiamo la
consapevolezza di misurare o di
prevedere quali saranno i lavori del
futuro
non tutto possiamo prevedere perché chi
immaginava che prima di internet
avessimo tutti questi influenzerà
youtube social media manager che fanno
un servizio un lavoro su internet era
imprevedibile
oggi come facciamo a prevedere che ci
saranno tanti lavori sull'intelligenza
artificiale e quali saranno questi tipi
di lavori imprevedibile
ci sono ovviamente persone che a oggi
già insegnano alle macchine operare ma è
un mondo assolutamente aperto quindi
dobbiamo restare molto ottimisti quello
che possiamo capire subito e che
dobbiamo fare più relazioni e meno
transazioni
la relazione è soltanto un attività che
aggiunge alla transazione la nostra
emotività la nostra empatia la nostra
riflessione di ri anche coscienza perché
ci mettiamo del nostro la transazione
invece un'attività meccanica
io do il soldino a una persona o alla
macchina la macchina mi dà il bene o il
tagliando quelle una transazione pura
per avere più lavoro domani dovremo fare
più relazioni per cui quando gli
agricoltori hanno visto il loro mondo
cambiare e hanno intravisto il loro
futuro nelle fabbriche perché il numero
dell'agricoltore è diminuito lo sappiamo
tutti quanto adesso è già da un po di
tempo il numero degli operai si sta
riducendo lo stiamo vedendo un po loro
vedono il loro futuro un po verso i
servizi ma tutti quelli che come noi
lavoriamo nel mondo dei servizi nel
mondo del terziario dove lo possiamo
vedere il futuro del lavoro a mio modo
di vedere noi siamo nella condizione di
avere tra noi miliardi di persone
i bisogni delle persone sono infiniti
noi possiamo vedere il lavoro degli
altri
negli occhi degli altri quindi credo che
il nostro futuro è la relazione con
l'altro le macchine questa relazione non
la possono svolgere mai
grazie